Thank you all very much.
Thank you,
Barbara for first and second for
attending.
So I'm going to try to do something very
difficult this evening.
I'm going to try to put the idea of the
rights,
the right to free speech in the broadest
possible historical context.
I want to start with a comment though.
You know we have an idea of built into
our human rights legislation that all
the rights are equal in some sense,
and that can't be true because rights
conflict with one another and when
things conflict they have to be
hierarchically organized and what that
means is that there's.
There's an implication that there is a
hierarchy of rights as well as the
hierarchy of responsibilities and that
it's also incumbent on us to determine
the nature of that hierarchy and to
determine what constitutes the
sovereign,
let's say the sovereign right and I
would say you might think of that as a
modern conundrum that would only be of
interest to countries that have
formalized bills of rights,
for example,
but it's not a new problem.
It's an extraordinarily old problem
because there is no difference between
determining the hierarchy of your rights
and determining how to live together
successfully.
It is exactly the same problem.
One is only articulated in the legal
forum and the problem of how we should
live together in the most productive
possible manner.
Everything considered is as old as
mankind itself.
In fact,
I would say far older than now because
the same problem the devil's social
animals weigh down the phylogenetic
chain and so this is an unbelievably
archaic problem now.
Years ago when I started thinking,
I suppose in in earnest,
I was trying to address what I later
recognized as a postmodern problem and
the problem was this was in the late
seventies and early eighties when the
Cold War was madly raging because it
peaked in 1962 and it peaked again in
about 1984 votes.
And of course at that time people were
very terrified about potential outcome
of the Cold War and for very good
reason.
And I was curious about.
I was curious about this,
like insanely curious about it.
It was obsessing me.
I couldn't understand.
Two things,
I couldn't understand why the world has
divided itself into two opposing
narratives,
why that had happened at all,
and also why these narratives were of
such importance to people apparently
that we were willing to arm ourselves
far beyond the teeth and risk massive
mutual annihilation to battle the battle
out.
The conflict between these two ways of
looking at the world.
And I was curious.
I mean,
first the first question were these
merely two ways of looking at the world
now because you might think,
well,
there's,
there's no shortage of ways to live in
the world.
That's a moral,
morally relativistic stance and there's
something to that obviously because
people,
different people,
different occupations and a different
outlook and,
and so forth at different,
different political beliefs.
So there's obviously many ways that we
can thrive in the world.
And so some degree of flexibility with
regards to what constitutes your
fundamental axioms,
obviously is,
is necessary.
Um,
but there's a deeper question and this
is a very deep question.
I actually think it's the question at
the bottom of the postmodern conundrum,
which is whether or not there are any,
um,
reliable Meta narratives,
let's say overarching narratives that
can unite people in some fundamental
way.
And so I was curious where were these
just to arbitrary ways of looking at the
world both potentially equally valid and
where we are battling that out because
we didn't know and there was no other
way to battle it out or was there
something deeper at stake?
Was it possible that one or the other
system was correct in some deep manner?
And I believe I do truly believe that I
entered that
that universe of questions,
let's say with as openness of mind is
possible because I actually wanted to
find out the answer,
you know,
because.
Well,
it seemed to me the fundamental question
that obviously we fought a whole cold
war about it was the fundamental
question.
Who was this?
It was the question everyone's minds
should have been concentrated on.
And so I started to study deeply this,
this particular question.
The first question was,
well,
what were beliefs made out of like what
exactly is it?
What are.
What are we talking about when we talk
about a belief,
what does it mean that you have beliefs,
our beliefs structured and also that was
a psychological question rather than a
political or economic question and that
took me a long time to figure out
because I didn't know if the fundamental
mental question was going to be
sociological or political or economic or
psychological energy turned out to be
psychological or perhaps it turned out
to be spiritual.
That's another way of thinking about it
and if,
if you could grasp beliefs,
what would constitute a credible belief
and what would it mean for a belief to
be credible?
And I can give you a little hint about
that.
I learned this from Shawn Psj,
the developmental psychologists,
brilliant,
brilliant theorists,
genuine genius.
He was interested in how children
organized games and he thought it's
games,
the organ or the Organization of Games
by children as the precursor to adult
interaction.
And he made some very interesting
observations about games.
You know,
especially pretend games which are quite
sophisticated because children will get
together and play pretend games and what
they'll do is they act out a simulation
of the world.
Maybe they play house,
they all get together and they cast each
other in different roles and then they
each act out those roles and they do
that and now in order to simulate
something that they're going to have to
adapt to.
But he has.
Jay noted a couple of things.
The first thing you noted was that
children playing games can play the
games in a group.
Thank you very much.
Can play a game in a group.
But if you take them out of the group
and you ask them what the rules of the
game are,
they don't know.
They can't articulate the rules of the
game yet.
When you put them together in the group,
they can play the game.
And I thought,
oh that's just like adults.
You see because.
Because.
Well,
because we wouldn't need a psychology
otherwise,
right?
Because we'd all be transparent to
ourselves already.
So what that means is when we all get
together and play a game like the one
that we're playing in this room,
for example,
we all can play the game when we're
together,
but if we brought us out and said,
well,
what are the rules,
we wouldn't able to articulate them.
And then I thought,
well that means that those rules evolve
in a real sense.
Like they evolved in a behavioral
competition and I thought,
well that's.
That's a lot like what's happening with
animals.
If you look at how a chimpanzee troop is
organized or a wolf pack and social
animals for that matter,
going way down the phylogenetic chain,
they have to interact with one another
in a manner that that sustains the group
because otherwise they all die obviously
and it sustains the individuals within
the group and offers the individual some
some scope of action.
And so there's a set of implicit
constraints on the manner in which
creatures interact or they don't live.
And and Piaget also came to the same
conclusion with regards to children's
games.
And this is where he made a distinction
that's so crucial because piaget was
actually interested in bridging the gap
between science and religion and I was
his fundamental,
it's fundamental motivation,
although very few people know that and
he was interested in bridging the gap
between science and ethics and,
and he was interested in how ethics
evolved as a,
as a concept and then as practically
applicable as something that was
practically applicable.
And he made some very interesting
comments about games and said,
well look what,
what constitutes a good game?
Ah,
well,
one rule is everybody plays voluntarily.
That's a really good game.
And then he made another claim which was
quite cool,
which was imagine that you had a game a
and B and b,
and they were competing against the
target and in,
in game beat,
people were being forced to play in a
game a people were playing voluntarily
and then you track their track record
with regards to competitors advantage.
Over time,
the game that people were playing
voluntarily would win because the people
who were playing wouldn't have to waste
any effort in enforcement costs.
I said,
Oh God,
that's so smart.
It's so smart because because you can
see the idea of the emergence of an
ethic theory and not an ethic that's
rationally constructed.
It's an ethic that's actually emerging
from the board.
I'm up now.
If the philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche,
he also pointed out that are,
that are epic actually emerged from the
bottom up.
It wasn't rational.
It wasn't top down.
It wasn't enlightenment oriented.
Even though the enlightenment might've
codifying it as part of a process of
notification that took place over a very
long period of time and so and then I
read other things to say about the way
that animals organized the troops.
This was later,
but it's relevant to our talk today that
primatologist Frans de Waal for example,
is trying to find out what makes
chimpanzee troops stable across time.
And you know,
you kind of have this idea that a
chimpanzee troop is driven,
let's say,
by the most dominant,
powerful male,
the most aggressive,
cruel,
tyrannical chimpanzee dominates.
And that isn't what friends do all
found.
What he found was that in order that
those sorts of chimpanzee troops have
leaders that meet very violent and
because no matter how Thai radical you
are as top Cim to chimps,
three quarters of your size can take you
out and they will and chimpanzees are
unbelievably,
unbelievably brutal and very,
very strong and so tyrannical chimpanzee
troops are unstable.
It's like that's how major league
discovery now because it starts to.
It starts to open up the possibility
that the ethic upon which functional
states are predicated is far deeper than
any near story or any near rationality,
and that's a really exciting possibility
because what it means is that there
might be something at the bottom of our
ethic that's really there.
It's not just some arbitrary constructed
narrative.
It's not just one set of ways to live in
the world among many and I would say I
would say,
and I tried to outline this partly in 12
rules for life and more in detail in
maps of meaning that the evidence on
that is already in is that there is a.
There is a convergence ethic that
emerges from the bottom up over
evolutionary spans of time over millions
of years,
over hundreds of thousands of years or
tens of thousands of years as people
learn how to act in a manner that
sustains them as individuals now and a
week from now,
a month from now,
a year from now,
so it has to be iterative that sustains
them and their families simultaneously.
It sustains them and their families and
their communities across all those
timeframes simultaneously and that's a
very,
very tight set of constraints and so
there might be a very large number of
ways to interpret the world as the
postmoderns postmodernists accurately
have it,
but there are not a very large number of
ways to exist successfully in the world.
In fact,
it's extraordinary to constraint.
It's constrained by the necessity of
playing an iterative voluntary game and
that's a tight constraint as any of you
who are married.
No.
Right.
Well,
I mean,
I mean there's absolutely definitively
because you see the marriages are very
interesting balancing act because it has
to be good for you and it has to be good
for your wife,
let's say,
but it also has to be good for the two
of you and it has to depend.
Maybe that's super ordinary to each of
you as individuals and it has to be good
for you in a way that's good for your
children and that has to work in society
and it has to be something that you can
play out moment by moment and hour to
hour,
day to day and month to month and week
to week.
And you know,
you know perfectly well that there isn't
much deviation from the straight and
narrow path if you're going to play that
game because there's just too many ways
of falling into trouble and there's way
more ways of falling into trouble.
The North falling into trouble.
Okay?
So,
so that's the first thing.
So imagine this.
So this is the,
this is the idea.
So
the ethic emerges from the bottom up.
As we learn how to organize ourselves in
evermore complex society,
sustainable societies,
and we don't know what we're doing,
okay,
but then what happens is because we are
insanely curious and capable of self
recognition,
we start to tell stories about how it is
that we're acting and the stories have
two forms.
One story is about the structures that
we exist in and that's the stories about
other people and every stories about
other people,
right?
Because we live in a social world and
you never see a story.
You never go to a movie,
you never read a novel that he isn't
about society and no wonder because
that's our environment society.
So stories are about society and they're
about how societies succeed and fail and
there about how individuals within that
society succeed or fail.
Because what we're trying to do is to
watch her.
So I mean again,
over the massive historical timeframes.
We're trying to watch how it is that we
act when we act properly and figure out
how to do it as individuals.
And the first way we do that is to coat
it in stories.
That's what stories are for.
That's what great literature is for.
That's why there are great villains and
great heroes and great literature
because you want to know how to be a
great hero unless you want to be a great
villain and if you want to be a great
hero,
you can learn from great villains the
opposite of how to act and so you get.
You get incredible,
incredibly sophisticated representations
emerging out of that process so that
they take on an archetype of form,
so for example,
the the,
the motif of the hostile brothers which
has developed into and Christianity into
the twin adversaries of Christ and Satan
or Cain and Abel are the idea of the
hero who thrives in the social world and
brings renewal to the cosmos,
so to speak,
against the deadly adversaries.
And that's exactly what you need to
know.
And again,
it's not arbitrary.
It's not an arbitrary set of
propositions.
It's predicated on the observation of
successful and unsuccessful patterns of
behavior over very,
very,
very long stretches of time.
So there's a behavioral platform and
then there's a narrative representation
of that platform.
Then the two things start to interact
because once you have drama and
literature,
you can learn from drama and literature
and ultra how you behave and your ethic
becomes portable and then what happens
after that is that
what happens after that is that thinkers
who now have both the behavioral strata
and the representational strata in front
of them,
the procedural ethic,
that behavioral ethic plus the story
representation.
Step one,
step back from that,
especially after it's written down.
This is why the Bible are of such
critical importance because the pattern,
the dramatic patterns are then written
down and then you can step back from
them with your consciousness and you can
start to analyze them for their,
for the rule based content.
You see that emerging to some degree in
the story of Moses.
That's actually what's laid out in part
in the story of Moses because Moses is
leading his people through the desert
and watching how they fight and watching
how they behave and then he has this
tree,
so it's all very,
very dramatic.
Then he has this tremendous revelation
which is this is how we already act.
Right?
And so what happens is the rules are
codified on the basis of the observation
of the patterns that are already extent
that are functional as the
transformation of consciousness.
At that point you have your ethic,
which is far deeper than anything that
you can imagine,
start to be articulated out into the
body of laws,
and that's the point at which you have,
let's say,
true philosophy and the beginning of the
body of laws.
It's called the body of laws for a
reason.
And so,
oh,
I thought that was all just amazing to
have who have to have observed them to
think about that bottom up process.
Then I started reading a lot of
religious mythology and I ran across
this motif that was developed very in
great detail by a Romanian Murcia,
Eliana,
who is a great scholar of religion.
So group wrote remarkable,
remarkable books including a history of
religious ideas,
which is highly recommended book.
And he talked about this interesting
motif that I had run across and other
writings on mythology and and,
and in religious stories,
which was the battle of the Gods in
heaven across time.
And one of the things they pointed out
was that if you,
if you looked at the development of
religious system,
so say the development of the religious
system that came to dominate in
Mesopotamia when the Mesopotamian tribes
came together.
So imagine each of those tribes have
their own gone,
right.
And then when they came together,
that was terribly fractious because you
know what happens when different people
with different gods get together,
it's suddenly it's ugly and it's no
wonder because you know,
they each have an ethic and they,
they're living within the ethic and
they're using it to structure their
worlds.
But the ethics apparently Clyde.
And so what happens at the civilization
level is that there's constant
negotiation and cognitive transformation
within the individual populations,
but that's represented over the large
span of time as a battle between the
gods that represent the different tribes
in heaven.
And so then what happens across time as
all those gods organized themselves into
a hierarchy and one God comes out on top
and that God is the Supreme God.
And then the society is like
Mesopotamia,
Mesopotamia.
That also happened in ancient Greece.
They assume that they're sovereign is
the person who acts out in a sovereign
God because you might say,
well,
where does the concept of sovereignty
come from?
Right?
If it's not just brute force and it's
not because brute force doesn't work,
it has to have some other basis.
What's the basis of sovereignty?
What's the basis of authority?
Not Power Authority,
competence,
authority,
right?
Well how has that played out?
It's played out by the battle between
ethics systems of ethics that are
represented in religious language across
vast epochs of time,
and then the societies of God's would
say organize themselves into a hierarchy
and they have a god at the top and
that's actually laid right out in the
Enuma elish for example,
which is the oldest creation story that
we have and out of which it's derived
from the same.
What would you say?
Cultural substrate as the stories in
genesis,
for example,
although it represents a variant,
the Mesopotamians had older gods
aggregate themselves together because
they were threatened by the unknown.
That's what happens in the.
In the Mesopotamian creation myth,
the unknown gives rise to the gods.
They become very fractious and compete,
and then the unknown decides to destroy
them again,
like God destroying Noah.
It was people in the flood.
It's the same basic idea.
There's an idea there.
The idea is that we emerge out of the
unknown and we're always threatened by
it,
not only as individuals but as a group,
and that means that we need to figure
out what it is that should guide us in
order to continually confront the
unknown and prevail.
And so what happens in Mesopotamia,
the gods all get together in a congress
and they basically,
they elect a new God and he's a new kind
of God.
His name is Martin,
by the way.
He has eyes all the way around his head
and so he pays attention.
That's not the same as thinking.
It's a different thing.
Attention,
it's the same thing.
The Egyptians representative in worship
with the eye of horus.
The idea that what you should do if you
want to survive in this world and if you
want to play a voluntary game that
everybody could participate in your
bloody eyes better be open because they
are the things that will save you,
and that's the tension and the other
thing that mark did,
he spoke magic words and so when he
spoke,
the night sky would appear.
The Day sky would appearance,
so the Mesopotamians figured out in
their great religious story that the
fundamental sovereign God was he who
pays attention and speaks the truth,
and that's something that's something
that's,
that's not something you punish people
for,
right?
Because there's this.
This is the deepest idea of mankind.
It's developed in detail in Genesis,
in the Old Testament.
It's the fundamental idea of genesis
that God uses the logos,
the word of God to cast hotel,
which we all face.
That's what we face.
Potential.
You know that you know that the future
is unstructured.
You have a.
You have a potential within you that can
meet that and there's a potential that
characterizes the future.
You meet it with eyes open,
end with truthful speech,
and that's what happens in genesis
because God uses the logos which is
truthful speech to cast the pre
cosmogony potential into habitable order
and then he says it's good and there
there's a hint there,
right?
Because you think,
well,
is habitable order good?
Because life is very difficult and it's
a real question whether or not the order
that we inhabit is good,
and the hypothesis in the Old Testament
is that if truthful speech gives rise to
the order,
then that order will be good and that's
really something man like that's really
something to apprehend.
It's fundamental theological
presupposition that the way that you
take the potential upon which the cosmos
is predicated and cast to the into the
order that allows everyone to thrive is
by using truthful speech.
Wouldn't be something if that was the
case and the thing is you know it's the
case.
You know you know it because you do not
admire yourself.
If you're deceitful,
you admire yourself.
When you have those rare moments in your
life where you can actually stand up and
say what's true regardless of the cost,
and if you,
if you give that respect to other
people,
if you treat them as if they're the
locale of the divine speech,
the casts potential into habitable
order,
then they like you,
maybe they even love you and they get
along with you when you could work with
them and you can cooperate with them and
you can compete with them.
So not only is it the,
the fundamental axiom that regulates
your relationship with yourself,
it's the fundamental axiom that
regulates your interactions with other
people and if you do not give them that
that honor,
which is the presupposition for their
natural.
Right?
Right.
Because the idea that you haven't
natural,
right,
is the idea that you have some sort of
intrinsic value.
If you don't treat people as if they
have that intrinsic right,
they are not happy with you.
Even if they don't know why,
because everyone wants to be treated as
if they have freewill and is if they
confront potential and as if they're
capable of making moral choices and that
they should be rewarded when they do
things right and perhaps punished when
they do things wrong.
Everyone wants that and everyone knows
it and so well.
So what does that all have to do with
free speech?
Well,
yes.
Everything.
That's exactly right.
So free speech isn't free speech.
You know,
people think of free speech is Kinda
like a decoration,
something like that in your life and
it's not that at all.
It's not the ability to speak truth to
power,
although it is also that.
It's not that.
It's way more than that.
Free speech is how you think.
It's not thinking.
You know the word genesis relies on to
create cosmos,
let's say in the story.
By the way,
that's the image of God in which you're
made male and female.
That gives you that fundamental value.
That's at the core of our idea of
natural,
right?
It's not thinking it's speaking and the
reason for that is,
first of all,
you can hardly think.
It's really hard to think.
You have to be trained,
like mad to think.
You have to be able to divide yourself
internally into a couple of different
people and then you have to let those
people have a war in your head and that
means you have to develop characters,
have opinions in great detail,
opinions that might be contrary to your
own and then you have to withstand the
tension of letting them have it out and
you only see that thinking in great
literature.
Like you see that in Dostoevsky.
He's an absolute master of that and you
know,
you can think a little bit,
but mostly you're biased and you have
confirmation bias and you see things the
way you see them and you have massive
blind spots in your ignorance as hell
and you just.
You just,
you just can't think.
But you can talk.
And the thing is if you talk,
other people will correct you.
That's the thing.
And that's thinking.
So if you get up and you have something
to say and you say it stupidly because
of course you will,
because what you know then other people
will tell you where you're wrong and
then you can learn,
right?
And then everybody can think.
And so what that also means is that to
be free,
to speak,
even to tell the truth means you have to
be free to be stupid and ignorant and
malevolent and bitter because that is
who you are.
That is what you are because you're a
fraud.
So the idea that
you know,
you can't use your free speech if it's
offensive,
it's just,
it's an idea that is so you don't know
if it's naive.
It does.
It's malevolence.
It's a real battle.
Which of the which of those two things
are worse?
I would go with malevolence because it
detracts suck at it tax.
Something that's so absolutely
fundamental.
It's like,
well of course people who are speaking
freely are going to be offensive.
I mean,
have you ever had a serious discussion
with anyone in your life?
And I'm in a serious discussion.
I mean this sort of discussion you have
when you're with your wife,
when you're wondering whether your
marriage is going to survive or you or
with your kids when they've done
something that is really not in their
best longterm interest,
I mean a serious discussion.
You can't even get off the ground
without being offensive.
You can't get off the ground with
defending yourself in a conversation
like that.
You don't even want to admit how you
feel or how you think to yourself.
If you think you can have a difficult
conversation without offending people,
all that means is you're not having a
difficult conversation because for an
easy conversation,
by definition,
no one gets upset about that.
There's no real problem.
There's no real disagreement.
There's and there's no real,
real world problem to be solved.
It's just trivial.
It's like discussing last night sports
event.
There's nothing to it.
If you're going to have a conversation
about something that matters in the
world is made out of what matters.
That's a good thing to remember.
If you're going to have a discussion
about what matters.
If you're really going to talk about
everyone is going to be offended by
that,
especially if there's something rotten
in the state of Denmark and you happen
to be the one that is pointing it out,
so then you think,
well,
your freedom of speech.
That's not about you being able to speak
truth to power.
That's about you being able to chart
your destiny in the world and more than
that,
it's even more important enough because
you know life is hard.
If you don't get to think.
When you.
When you walk through your life,
you will fall into a pit.
There's no doubt about that because
that's what thinking is for,
is to stop you from having any more
catastrophes that are absolutely
necessary and it's a terribly difficult
process.
And so if,
if that's interfered with,
it isn't that you don't get to speak
truth to power.
It's that you do not get to act in the
world in a manner that allows you to to
eliminate endless,
unnecessary,
hellish suffering and not just for you
but for you and your family and your
community.
And so the enemies of free speech.
They're the enemies of the process that
turns potential into habitable order.
There are enemies of the divine
principle and worse,
they're their own enemies,
right?
Because this isn't.
Well,
some of us believe in free speech,
and some of us don't.
It's way deeper than that.
If you don't believe in free speech,
you don't believe in the implicit
divinity of mankind.
You don't believe in the sovereignty of
the individual.
You don't believe in sovereignty as
such.
You're a totalitarian of some sort,
which means you attribute all the divine
power to yourself and then we know where
that leads,
right?
It doesn't matter whether it's on the
right or the left.
If we had any sense that we took a look
at 20th century history,
we know exactly things go and we could
easily choose not to go there.
And so when we see someone like Ryan
who's in prison by a reprehensible
dictatorships that we have the gall to
call our lis than what we see is a
system that's not only hell bent on the
destruction of an innocent and good man,
but,
but directly antithetical to everything
that all of us have.
Our society's put forward as necessary
to the continual betterment of being
itself.
No.
Am I being so absolutely appalled by the
Western world.
We need response to the attacks of
totalitarians upon our freedom of speech
though the what was done with Solomon
Rushdie,
that was a big,
big,
big mistake,
right?
Because it wasn't rushed.
It was the free speaking artistic
tradition of the West and not only of
the West,
right?
The free speaking,
artistic,
creative tradition upon which the cosmos
is properly established.
That's what it was and we all bow down.
We all bowed down with no resistance
whatsoever.
It was a massive error.
We're going to pay for that for a very
long time.
We did the same thing with the Danish
cartoons
and you don't want to think about these
sorts of things is happening far away.
Nothing happens far away when it
happened somewhere else.
It's happening right here too,
and that's why we're all here today
because we recognize that at least on
some level and we have to stop.
We need to stop being so naive about
our,
let's say our moral relativism.
We need to take a look at history and
biology in a very,
very fundamental way and we need to
really understand what our culture,
what our culture and cultures everywhere
are predicated on,
and that is the idea that the sovereign
voice of the individual is the power
that casts potential into habitable and
restructures,
tyrannical order,
when it needs to be restructured.
Right,
and that's what each of us are.
That's the divine presence in each of
us,
and I do believe that there is no more
fundamental truths than that.
I don't believe that you can dig down
underneath that.
I think that's bedrock.
That's the foundation stone of the
house,
that's the cornerstone of the house,
and it requires everyone to courageously
confront the tyranny,
that's them and the unknown that
surrounds them and to work for their own
benefit and for the benefit of their
families and for the benefit of their
communities and to do everything they
can to benefit the world and to live
with true speech as the highest value.
That's how we sorted out the world and
we can sort it out.
We are sorting it out at a very rapid
rate and we could do that much,
much more effectively.
I do believe that it's incumbent on us
to understand the absolutely fundamental
role that these processes take.
I know we're here today because we all
have at least an intimation of that.
Great.
We know that there's something about
free speech that's central,
that we cannot allow a tax on it to go
unchallenged,
no matter where they occur,
but it's very useful to have an
articulated and to know that this is
bedrock,
right and it's not something arbitrary
and it's not a mere game that we're only
playing in the west.
None of that.
It's something.
It's the most fundamental truth that the
human race has ever discovered and we
lose it at our absolute peril and it's
not that it's worse than that,
the peril because there are worse things
than death and the worst things than
death is hell.
And we saw plenty of that in the 20th
century and when we left freedom of
speech go,
that's where we're headed and unless we
want to go there,
then we should stop aiming for.
Thank you,
so thank you very much for the
invitation.
Can I?
Thank you.